gençler Merhaba hepiniz hoş geldiniz
sınıflandırma konusuna başlıyoruz
biyolojinin Aslında en kapsamlı konusu
Tabii ki biz belli başlı noktalara
değineceğiz ve MEB'in gösterdiği yerlere
vurgu yapacağız Hadi gelin birlikte
öğrenelim şimdi herhangi bir yere
sınıflandırmanın temel amacı nedir diye
yazsanız Muhtemelen böyle bir cümle
çıkar işte bir kütüphanede binlerce
kitap var ve biz bu binlerce Kitabın
nerede olduğunu hangi konuyla alakalı
olduğunu bulabilmek için belli bir
dizilim belli bir numaralandırma işlemi
yaparız Aslında sınıflandırmanın temel
mantığında da bu var gerçekten canlıları
belli özelliklerine göre kategorize
ediyor ve o canlıların atalarıyla ya da
ondan sonra oluşacak canlılarla ilişki
kurmaya çalışıyor ve bu sayede sistemli
bir bilgi birikimi elde etmiş oluyor
şimdi baktığınız zaman tabii dünyada 1.2
milyon canlı türü keşfedildiği
söyleniyor ancak dünyanın oluşum
döneminden bugüne kadar bundan çok daha
fazla canlı olduğunu biliyoruz En
azından elde ettiğimiz fosil kaynakları
bize bunu gösteriyor ve sınıflandırmada
bir Gözümüz de geçmişe bakıyor geçmiş
değerlendirilerek olası türler ya da
olması gereken türler şeklinde yorumlar
da yapılıyor Çünkü kayıp türlerimiz var
hani hala ulaşamadığımız türler var
mantığı özellikle paleontoloji ve o tarz
bilim dallarında Biz bunu çok ön planda
tutuyoruz ve bakın cümleye kitapların ve
canların sınıflandırılması bilgiyi
düzenlemenin ve kolay erişilebilir hale
getirmenin bir yoldur Aslında Neyi
nerede bulmamız gerektiğini de bize
söyleyecek sınıflandırma şimdi ilk iki
soruya bakalım canların
sınıflandırılarak incelenmesinin
sağladığı faydalar nelerdir bakın
temelde bunlar karşım çıkacak Öncelikle
düzen sağlar bilimsel iletişimi
kolaylaştırır yani Bu ne demek şimdi siz
bir canlı keşfettiniz işte çok farklı
bir kıtada başka bir canlı keşfedildi
başka bir bilim insanı tarafından acaba
Siz aynı canlıyı mı keşfettiniz Ya da
bir canlıyla alakalı konuşacağınız zaman
gidip de işte kedi demezsiniz Çünkü
bilimsel literatürde hangi kedi felis mi
panthera mı yani bunlara baktığınız
zaman Arkadaşlar bir bilimsel iletişim
dili kurmuş oluyorsunuz yeni türlerin
keşfine olanak sağlayacak Çünkü ne dedim
bir geçmişe bakacak Bir de gelecekte ne
tarz şeyler bizi bekliyor onunla ilgili
yorum yapacak ama buradaki mantığımız şu
bir Silsile var bir canlı oluşum
silsilesi var Dolayısıyla buradaki
formlar ve ara formlarla ilgili yorum
yapacak tabii biz size çok böyle Evrim
vesaire anlatmıyor ama emin olun
arkadaşlar sınıflandırma bilimi evrimden
çok beslenir Canlar arasındaki
ilişkileri anlamamıza yardımcı olur
nesli tükenen canlılar ile günümüzdeki
canlılar arasında benzerlik kurulmasını
sağlar Peki bilim insanları
keşfettikleri yeni canlı türlerini
mevcut keşfedilenler arasında Nasıl
konumlandırır yani siz bir canlı
buldunuz şimdi ben bu canlıyı nereye
koyacağım bunu neye göre yapıyorsunuz
Aslında soru Bu elbette morfolojik Yani
bir dış görünüşüne önce bakarsın fakat
şunu unutmayın asla dış görünüş tek
başına sınıflandırmada yeterli değildir
fizyolojik özelliklerine biyokimyasal
özelliklerine dna'sına RNA moleküler
düzeydeki özelliklerine bakılır organ
benzerliklerine anatomisine bakılır Ve
dolayısıyla böyle bir sonuç ortaya çıkar
biyoinformatik soru işareti yapmışım
Orada biyoinformatik aslında bilgisayar
bilimini kullanarak yazılım bilimini
kullanarak DNA ile ilgili proteinle
ilgili mrna ile ilgili çalışmalar yapan
bilim dalıdır çok da Karizmatik bir
bilim dalıdır bir ara incelemenizi
tavsiye ederim filogenetik yani bunun
soyağacına Bak atasına bak sahip olduğu
özellikler atasında aynı mı benzer mi
yoksa ne kadar değişmiş bunlara bak ve
bilimsel adlandırma yaparak bunu bilim
camiasıyla paylaş şeklinde
sınıflandırmanın temel bir kuralı var
aslında bu sınıflandırmanın kökenine
baktığımızda çok fazla sınıflandırma
tipi var fakat Biz şu anda filogenetik
sınıflandırma yani doğal sınıflandırmayı
kullanıyoruz geçmişte birçok bilim
insanı sınıflandırma yapmış Çünkü
arkadaşlar insan ihtiyaçları
doğrultusunda canlıları tanıma gayreti
içerisine girmiştir burada değinilmemiş
ama benim benim mesela öğrencilerime
sıkça sınıf derslerinde tartıştığım bir
konu var O da işte Aristo ve
arkadaşlarının yaptığı sınıflandırma çok
çok çok geçmişte yapılan sınıflandırma
işte Canlar uçanlar yürüyenler yüzenler
şeklinde sınıflandırılmış Tabii ki hocam
bu çok bilimsel olmasa da insanların
hiçbir şeyin farkında değilken birinin
çıkıp canları sınıflandırmaya çalışması
çok büyük bir olay olduğu için kıymetli
oluyor ama biz şu anda ne kullanıyoruz
hocam filogenetik sınıflandırmayı
kullanıyoruz yani şu an gördüğünüz
özellikler işte genetik analiz
filogenetik biyokimya moleküler biyoloji
bu tarz özelliklerini kullanarak
canlının sınıflandırma yapıyoruz insan
faydalanma esasına göre canlıları
sınıflandırır dedik ancak Buradan şunu
da hatırlamanız istiyorum mesela sadece
gözle görülür canlılar değil mikroskobik
canlıları da sınıflandırıyoruz yani
burada herhangi bir mikroorganizmanın
bize zarar verme ihtimali var mı Varsa
hangi özellikleriyle bize zarar veriyor
ve biz buna karşı ne geliştirebiliriz
Kendimizi nasıl koruyabiliriz bunu da
yapmış oluyoruz bakın burada mikropların
doğru tanımlanması hastalıkların teşhis
ve tedavisinde oldukça önemlidir
tarzında çok güzel bir cümle var Ve
tabii nesli tehlike altında olan canlara
daha yakından takip fırsatı da veriyor
bize sınıflandırma
bilimi şimdi biyolojik sınıflandırma
sisteminde aslında bir sistematik Bir de
sınıflandırma mantığı var sistematik
biliminde tanımlama adlandırma ve
sınıflandırma yapılıyor Biz ise size
sınıflandırmayı yani taksonomiye
anlatıyoruz Temel esaslarıyla ve takson
ifadesine bakın her bir sınıflandırma
kategorisinde yer alan belirli ortak
özelliklere sahip canlı grubuna takson
denir Mesela biz soruları çözerken
özellikle şöyle bir ifade kullanacağız
hocam tür
cins
aile takım sınıf şube ve Alem şeklinde
türden aleme doğru şu şekilde sürekli
eliniz alışsın yaza yaza gidin işte
Türkiye Cumhuriyeti ağ takımı sahada şut
attı şeklinde öğretmenlerimiz
kısaltabilir leyen bilim dalı neymiş
taksonomi miş Aslında sınıflandırma
eşittir taksonomi şeklinde ifade
edebilirsiniz şimdi şuraya dikkat edelim
taksonomi bilimi canlıları tanımlama
çalışmalarında Morfoloji yani canlının
dış görünüşüyle ilgilenen bilim dalı
anatomi Histoloji anatomi canlıların
organlarını Histoloji dokularını
biyokimya hücresel düzeydeki
tepkimelerini moleküler biyoloji Aslında
DNA Temelli olan işlemleri mesela
protein sentezi gibi RNA sentezi gibi
işlemleri inceleyen bilim dalları ve
bunların hepsini arkadaşlar bakın bir
şekilde taksonomide kullanıyorsunuz
Çünkü canlıların akrabalık derecelerini
anlayabilmeniz için onları genelden
özele doğru sınıflandırmanın lazım ve
buradaki mantık önce Makro yapılara
bakıyorsun
sonra mikro yapılara ve hücresel
düzeydeki birtakım tepkimelere
bakıyorsunuz bu şekilde canlıyı
sınıflandırıyoruz ve ne dedik Hocam şu
anda günümüzde kullandığımız modern
sınıflandırmanın adı doğal sınıflandırma
yani filogenetik sınıflandırma lütfen
unutmayalım bakın Az önce de söyledim
DNA ve RNA dizilerinin incelenmesi ve
karşılaştırılması işte bioinformatik
gibi genetik gibi moleküler biyoloji
gibi bilimleri kullanarak nokta atış
akrabalık ilişkilerini bulmaya
çalışıyoruz canlıların sınıflandırmada
temel kategori türdür bakın en alta
Yazdığım En spesifik kavram türdür tür
nedir hocam ortak atadan gelen ve
çiftleştiğinde verimli döl oluşturabilen
canlılardır buradaki verimli dölden
kastım şu eğer X ve Y canlısı
çiftleşiyor ve z gibi bir canlı
oluşuyorsa bu X ve Y canlısının Aynı tür
olduğunu kanıtlamaz gidip de Z canlısı T
canlısı ile çiftleşip k gibi bir canlı
meydana yorsa İşte o zaman X ve Y aynı
türdür diyebiliyorsunuz Neden Çünkü X ve
y'nin yavrusu verimli döl oluyor yani
kendisinden sonra neslin devamının
gelmesini sağlıyor O yüzden bu ifadeye
de lütfen dikkat edin iki canlının
çiftleşebilir onları Aynı tür yapmaz
Tamam Aynı tür olabilmesi için verimli
yavrulara sahip olması lazım yani x ile
y'nin Zamanı gelince dede ve nine olması
lazım
canlıları adlandırırken çok güzel bir
adlandırma sistemimiz var bunu İsveçli
Doğa bilimci KL linne ilk oluşturuyor e
Carlin Bana da çok yakın bir mesafede
mezarı bir gün ziyaret edeceğim ve
hepiniz adına ona bilime yaptığı
katkılardan dolayı teşekkür edeceğim
Peki hocam ikili adlandırma binominal
adlandırma nasıl yapılır Aslında bakın
mesela burada fritillaria imperialist
yani ters lalenin bilimsel adı
gösterilmiş bakın ilk kelime cinstir
ikinci kelime ise özellik ya da
tanımlayıcı kelimedir ikisine birden tür
adı denir Tamam bu ifadede neymiş ilki
cins ikincisi özellik ikisine birden tür
adı denir ve dikkat edin arkadaşlar
italik yazılmış fritillaria imperialist
italik bir şekilde gösterilmiş ilk
kelime büyük harfle başlamış geriye
kalan her şey küçük harf ve ilk kelime
cins adı ikincisi özellik ya da
tamamlayıcı kelime olacak Tamam peki
birbirine yakın türlerin bir araya
gelerek oluşturduğu kategori cins yani
cins türün hemen üstünde birbirine yakın
bir sürü tür var Bunlar cinsi
oluşturuyor işte Ne dedik tür cins sonra
birbirine yakın cinsler aileyi aileler
takımı takımlar sınıfı sınıflar şubeyi
şubelerde Alemleri oluşturacak şimdi
baktığınız zaman hayvanlar alemi burada
Omurgaların üstünü çizmişiz arkadaşlar
Çünkü dün yaptığımız toplantıda
öğretmenlerim le beraber Aslında
omurgalı ifadesinin üniversitedeki
hocalarımız tarafından da kabul
edilmediğini söyleyeyim Onlar da çok
kızıyor biz böyle söylediğimizde şube
omurgalı değildir arkadaşlar şube kord
dalıdır korda sırt ipliği sinir şeridi
demek emin olun bunu 4 sene içerisinde
çözeceğiniz testlerde çok sık görmeye
başlayacaksınız şimdiden Lütfen buna
alışın şube omurgalı değildir arkadaşlar
omurgalılar gruptur hayvanlar alemi
kordalılar şu Esi memeliler sınıfı
etçiller takımı felide Ailesi panthera
yani büyük kediler cinsi ve bakın bir
tane tür panthera tigris yani Kaplan ben
bir de burada size Ev Kedisi felis bakın
onun cinsi felis tanımlayıcı adı katus
felis katus Ev Kedisi bunu da yine çok
sık testlerde göreceksiniz diye yazdım
şimdi dikkat edin Burada soru değeri en
kıymetli olan yer burası alemden Türe
doğru nasıl bir değişim olur yani
hayvanlar alemi diyorsun ama bir yerde
direkt Pantera tigris diye bir tane tür
var elinde O zaman ne yaptın bak
genelden özele geldin Dolayısıyla
alemden Türe doğru birey sayısını
azalttım çeşitliliği azalttım bak Dikkat
et farklı gen sayısını azalttım Yani
aslında bir başka ifadeyle ortak gen
sayısını ortak özellik sayısını protein
benzerliğini gen benzerliğini DNA
benzerliğini
artırdınız zaman da akrabalık derecesini
arttırmış oldun o zaman alemden Türe
doğru gelinde protein benzerliği gen
benzerliği DNA benzerliği artar
akrabalık artar birey sayısı azalır
çeşitlilik azalır Anlaştık mı bu tarz
bir soruyla kesinlikle karşılaşacağın
garantisini veriyorum herhangi bir
testte ya da yazılıda
mutlaka öğrenmen gerekiyor Tamam
peki şimdi Çevrenizde gördüğünüz canları
bireysel olarak listeleyiniz tarzında
bir ifade var ve buradaki listeledi
canlıları kendinizce kategorize edin
Özelliklerini söyleyin sınıflandırma
yapsaydınız Neyi kullanırdınız Onu
belirleyin E bir de bilimsel olarak da
gidin inceleyin bilimsel adını da
söyleyin şeklinde bir çalışma Ben kedi
Serçe çam ve çimi seçtim hocalarım ve
dedim ki
en alta bakın canlının bilimsel adı kedi
Ev Kedisi felis katus Serçe passer
montanus Tabii hocam serçenin birçok
türü var ama biz bunu seçmiş olduk
çamağacı pinus nigra yine çok
duyacağınız şey lolium perenne bu da çim
şimdi sizi uyarayım bu tarz Latince
ifadeleri öğrenmek zorunda falan
değilsiniz sadece şunu bilmek
zorundasınız Bu bir bilimsel isim ilk
kelime cins kelime tamamlayıcı at İkisi
birden tür adı Tamam Sizin bunu bilmeniz
lazım ve italik yazılıyor hocam kediye
baktım ben mesela genel kültür tadında
Hiç öyle bilimsel sınıflandırma falan
bilmiyorum hareket ettiğini görüyorum
diğer hayvanlarla beslendiğini görüyorum
doğruyor yavrusunu sütle beslediğini
görüyorum
evcilleştirilebilir vahşi değil bakın
Bunlar benim gözlemim sonucunda bir
öğrenciyim öğrenci olarak gözlem
yapıyorum Bir de kürke sahip olduğunu
görüyorum sonra diyorum ki sınıflandırma
yapsaydım özellikle diğer canlılarla
kıyaslamak için neyi kullanmak isterdim
sütü kürkü neden işte vücudu ne ile
kaplı yavrusunu ne ile besliyor doğurma
olayı mı var yumurtlama olayı mı var bu
tarz şeylerle bilimsel bir yaklaşıma
gidebilirdim ve bakın kendi gruplama
sisteminde Elbette ki hayvan ama modern
sistemde Sınıfı memeliler sınıfı olacak
serçeye baktım klasik bir öğrenci olarak
gözlem yapıyorum işte uçuyor yumurtluyor
Gaga yapısına sahip bakıyorum dişi mişi
falan yok ve vücut örtüsü tük sonra da
diyorum ki bunu ben bilimsel olarak
sınıflandırmak istesem önce vücut örtüsü
Çünkü az önce post vardı kıl vardı
burada bu sefer tüy var bir de az önceki
doğuruyordu şimdiki yumurtluyor şeklinde
bir yaklaşımda bulunabilirim ve sınıfı
da bakın Kuşlar sınıfı Yani aslında hani
hocam sen kuş diyorsun ama sınıf olarak
da kuş kullanılıyor çam ağacına
bakıyorum gözlem yapıyorum işte
yaprakları diken şeklinde kozalakları
var hiç çiçek görmüyorum meyve
görmüyorum E bir de böyle baktığım zaman
kışın yapraklarını dökmeyen bir canlı
olarak karşıma çıkıyor ağaç çam ağacı ve
Diyorum ki bu kendi
kategorimiz canlı ülkemizde yapraklarına
bakıyorum şerit şeklinde ve eğer çimi
yerinden sökersem hiç öyle diplere kadar
gitme ihtimali olan kazık kök yapısı
görmüyorum çektim böyle baktım saçak
saçak kökler gördüm daha böyle yüzeye
yayılmış durumda ve baktığım zaman Hocam
bu odunsu bir şey değil otsu bir şey
Peki ben bilimsel bir sınıflandırma
yapmak istesem hangi özelliklerini diğer
bitkilerle karşılaştırmak isterim yaprak
yapısını ya da kök yapısını ya da otsu
odunsu özellik var mı yok mu bu tarz bir
karşılaştırma yaparım kendi gruplama
sistemime buna od derim Ama baktığım
zaman bilimdeki sınıfına monokotiledon
Aslında Türkçesi tek çenekli yee yakın
ve bilimsel adına da baktığımda lolium
perenne olduğunu görürüm Peki bu
çalışmamızı da yapmış olduk şimdi burası
çok kıymetli bir yer burada her şeyi
özetlemek istiyorum size Hatta şöyle bir
temizleyeyim Şurayı bakın Normal şartlar
altında canlı sınıflandırılmasında
alemden tür seviyesine gelike Benzerlik
ne oluyordu artıyordu DNA benzerliği gen
benzerliği protein benzerliği değil mi
Dolayısıyla bu ifade doğru olduğu için
doğru tarafına yönleniyor pinus nigra ve
pinus Pia Aynı cins içinde bakın ilk
kelime cinsi değil mi ilk kelime cins ve
ikisi de aynı olduğuna göre Evet hocam
doğru bir ifade doğal sınıflandırma
akrabalık derecelerine göre yapılır
Bizim derdimiz o canlıları akrabalığa
göre sınıflandırmak Bu da doğrudur ve
birinci çıkıştan hakkıyla çıkarsınız
tamam şimdi diğer yorumlara da bakalım
Mesela panthera tigris ve panthera
pardüs aynı türeme ait hocam bir kere
aynı tür olabilmesi için iki kelimenin
de aynı olması lazım Pantera tigris
Pantera tigris bunlar bir cinsin iki
türü Tamam Pantera cinsinin iki türü
panthera tigris ve panthera pardüs Peki
hocam tür birbirleriyle üreyebilen ve
doğurgan yavrular meydana getirebilen
bireyler grubu muydu Evet doğru bir
ifade şuraya bakalım morfolojik
karakterler modern sınıflandırmada ayırt
edici bir karakter olarak kullanılmaz
olur mu morfolojiyi de kullanıyoruz ama
cümlemiz şöyle Olmalı tek başına
kullanılamaz Tamam tek başına böyle dış
görünüşe bakarak bilimsel sınıflandırma
yapamazsınız Ne kaldı taksonomi
canlıların sadece fiziksel özelliklerine
dayalı olarak yapılan bir
sınıflandırmadır olur mu hocam o kadar
şey söyledin anatomisi fizyolojisi
biyokimyası moleküler düzeydeki DNA RNA
özellikleri protein özellikleri Ben
bunlara bakarak yapıyorum sadece dış
görünüşüne fiziksel özelliğe bakarak
sınıflandırma yapılır mı yapılmaz o
zaman her uçana kuş derdim Halbuki
içlerinde ne var yarasa var yarasa da
memeli Tamam bunları ileride hayvanları
daha yakından tanıdığımız da size zaten
örnek örnek söyleyeceğim şimdi Bugün
sadece mantığı anlamaya çalışacağız
sınıflandırmada Ne yapıyoruz nasıl
sınıflandırma yapıyoruz bunu öğrenmeye
çalışacağız bir etkinlik var aslında
tayin anahtarı çok zor bir şeydir
Arkadaşlar bir canlıyla alakalı tayin
anahtarı Yazdığınız zaman öyle sayfalar
yüzlerce binlerce sayfa yazabilirsiniz
burada basitleştirilmiş bir versiyon
kullanılmış buralarda şöyle bir şey var
hani bize resimler verilmiş Bu
resimlerdeki canlılarla alakalı buraya
özellikler yazılmış ve bunların hangi
canlı olduğunu söylememizi istiyor çok
rahat bir şekilde arkadaşlar yazılanları
Okuduğunuz zaman sonuca ulaşacaksınız ya
mesela burada şöyle bir şey var pinus
Anadolu'da geniş bir dağılıma sahip
hızlı büyüyen kozalaklı ağaç grubudur
yaprakları ikili Demetler halinde iğne
şeklindedir koyu yeşil renk sert ve
biraz sivridir Bakıyorum bu tanıma Uyan
kim var E hocam pinus nigra var E bu çam
türü Anadolu'da çok sık gördüğümüz pinus
nigra yani Kara çamı olarak
türkçeleştirilmiş
burada son olarak bunu da yapalım ve
bitirelim domainlere geçmiyoruz
domainlere haftaya geçeceğiz bakın pinus
nigra pinus brua allium cadum
liquidambar
orientalis thermopsis tursika
fritillaria
imperialis hocam bu tarz canlılara
baktım Bunlarla ilgili şu anda hiçbir
fikrim yok ama esas şey neydi bilimsel
isimlendirme nasıl yapılır ona
bakacaksın 4 maddeden başlıyorum tabloda
verilen canlılardan hangilerinin genetik
benzerliği daha fazladır yani cinse
kadar inmiş a ile b sonra bir cinsin iki
türü olmuş Ne dedim ben size alemden
Türe doğru geldiğinde akrabalık derecesi
artar E ben şurada cinse kadar
gelebilmiş Bir zahmet pinus nigra ve
pinus bruın akrabalıkları yüksek olsun 3
madde doğal sınıflandırmaya göre tabloda
kaç adet cins bulunur ilk kelimelere
bakacağım pinus
alium liquidambar
termopil silara baktım hocam 5 tane var
doğal sınıflandırmaya göre Peki kaç adet
tür var hocam Bunların hepsi farklı tür
cinsi farklı olanın türü aynı olabilir
mi ilk kelimelere bakıyorsun ilk
kelimeler farklıysa zaten cinsler fark
hocam cinsi farklı olan aynı tür olamaz
6 tane şimdi 1 soruyu öyle lise
bilgisiyle sadece bakarak anlayamazsınız
Ancak şöyle olsaydı soru çok daha güzel
olurdu yukarıda verilen canlılardan
hangilerinin aynı takımda olduğu
kesindir sadece buraya bakarak mesela a
ile B'nin aynı takımda olduğuna
kesinlikle ikna olabilirdin Neden Çünkü
size öğreteceğim en önemli ve bu dersin
son güzel şeyi şimdi türden aleme doğru
gidildikçe tür cins aile takım sınıf
şube ve Alem şeklinde yazıyorsunuz ya
Eğer iki canlının cinsi aynıysa
üstündeki bütün basamaklarda beraberdir
fakat sonrasını bilemezsiniz Olabilir de
olmayabilir de o zaman burada 1 soruya
baktığımızda hangilerinin aynı takımda
olduğu kesindir diye sorduklarında ben
bakıyorum
şu ik canlının cinsi aynıysa Ailesi de
takımı da sınıfı da şubesi de alemi de
aynıdır
diyebilirsiniz bir örneklendir hocam bir
tane daha bize örnek ver mesela iki tane
canlı var a ve b canlısı ikisinin takımı
aynı Sizce aile cins türde mi Kesin
beraberler Yoksa daha genel olan sınıf
şube alemde mi Tabi ki Daha genel olan
yerde beraberler Çünkü hocam sen takıma
kadar mişsin genelden özele kadar şimdi
takımdan Sonrasını bilmiyorum hocam
ayrılabilir devam da edebilir Ama üst
tarafta beraber oldukları Yani genel
bölgede beraber oldukları kesindir Buna
dikkat edeceksiniz işte Bence en önemli
İkinci soru tipi buydu Çünkü alemden
Türe doğru gidildikçe ne artar ne azalır
bunu bilmeniz ve burada Nasıl yorum
yapmanız gerektiği önemli Arkadaşlar
şimdi baktığınızda ben tabii hocalarım
beraber hem kubil hocamla hem de Tuncay
hocamla ne yaptık işte Onların
takımlarını da gösterdik işte pinales
pinales asparagales liliales fabales sxi
frag ALES Bunlar bunun takımları yani
her bir canlının ait olduğu takımlar
gördüğünüz gibi takımları farklı zaten
cevap yine a b olacaktı ama tekrar
söylim bir öğrencinin bunu bilme
zorunluluğu asla yok lisede sadece şöyle
bir ifade kullanması lazımdı hangisinin
aynı takımda olduğu kesindir demesi
lazımdı ve sonuç itibariyle Siz cinse
aynı olanın zaten Ailesi takımı sınıfı
şubesi alemi aynıdır deyip Soruyu
çözecek diniz Evet Bugünlük bu kadar
yeter Önümüzdeki hafta domain mantığı
bakteri ve arkeleri işleriz Umarım
anlaşılmıştır hepinize kolay gelsin